so the whole real issue at the UN right
now is that this unveiling of the new
president of Iran rouhani and they're
calling it the charm offensive and he's
sitting down with American media and he
sat down with Christiane Amanpour we're
gonna get to her in just a moment but I
want to show you just a little bit of
the beginning of their interview hello
mr. president
nice to see you so America nice to see
you again exactly please welcome to CNN
thank you for doing this for us I want
to ask you what it feels like to be what
some people have called the it man of
this ung a highly-anticipated you seem
to be the focus of attention and
unusually for Iranian presidents people
are looking at you with some at least
cautious optimism what does it feel like
to be in this position God blessing care
before responding to your question I'd
like to actually extend my greetings to
the people of America who are very dear
and near to the hearts of the Iranian
people and to wish them a good time and
good times ahead a good time and good
times
I'm pretty sure he's talking about the
sitcom okay so this is very typical of
what Amanpour does she cozies up to all
these people and then they say things
that are you know oh it's a good that
we're gonna have a good time
everything's great meanwhile you know
they don't have Facebook and Twitter
they had it for like a day last week in
Iran and then it was taken away you know
gay people are still being put to death
in all kinds of horrible stuff that
everybody knows about but they use our
media to make themselves feel better and
appear better is it nuts that we let our
Western media we're free here so we let
everyone talk but is it a little nuts
that we let everybody talk to us in this
in this fashion I mean everyone or I I
think she does this was specifically
good job at really like nudging that
like giving under the table tugs are
these these people that you're using
we're gonna get to that yes I mean it's
literally like I feel like she's sitting
down it should be like a entertainment
news in the background she's like
interviewing him unlike the latest movie
that he's
like you you look great you're great job
how are the kids
it's like the man of the man you were
great on that red carpet it is and
that's why he has the Liberty he he
should feel comfortable being like I'd
like to just take a minute and just talk
about hey everyone hope you're having a
good time babies and you know it's like
its peak especially in this situation
it's just kind of narrowed down to a
ridiculous day yeah it's not even
dealing with issues like you're avoiding
any serious all right well before we
bring that point really home what do you
think about them using the Western media
because we do have free media here so
they should be elected yeah I think
absolutely we should have it by all you
know means that really for rights and
forward you know everyone should have a
voice and we should hear all sides and
all of that unfortunately their voice
and their voice is part of the voices
that have to be heard so but to your
fact when he's like chilling and relaxed
and what I mean if you were if you're
really you know you're the president
Mehran like you're a huge figure and
you're sitting down with a serious
journalist who's gonna be asking you
hard-hitting questions yeah wouldn't you
be a little nervous wouldn't you be
sweating a little bit like sweating like
Paula Deen at the BT or sweat no just
something like a little simmer I mean
the fact that they're so relaxed it's
like they know that it it's [ __ ]
right well didn't he didn't sweat in
that interview but he did sweat at the
United Nations yeah that's good at least
but okay so the reason I wanted to bring
that clip up and really focus on
Christiane Amanpour is because she does
have a history of interviewing these
people pushing their propaganda and then
talking about it after even which is
even more furthering their ideas so this
is two years ago remember Mohammad Morsi
he was the Muslim Brotherhood leader who
then was voted in democratically but
everyone knew he wasn't gonna bring
democracy and then he got deposed and
now he's in jail in Egypt right now not
a good guy did not do any other things
he said he was going to do but here she
is interviewing him right before he was
voted in the slogan has come back again
and there are people who are concerned
that a Muslim Brotherhood which wins the
presidency and dominates the Parliament
could introduce fundamentalist theocracy
and Islamic theocracy what do you say to
that
people are freely making their choice
now and they are the ones who chose the
Parliament we are talking about
elections and democracy if the Egyptian
people have chosen their leaders then
there won't be any room for worry we
want to transform from a president of
the institution to an institution of the
presidency to an executive branch that
represents the people's true will and
implements their public ok so there's
literally not a word of truth there that
the people's will which then he defied
for a year and made it
democracy much worse and crackdown on
freedom of speech and all that stuff and
she just gives them a forum for this is
this I mean we're gonna talk a little
more about the media later but should we
expect more from our media you know why
why doesn't she lose credibility after
doing an interview like that and then
she does the ruhani interview two years
later and everyone thinks that's great
and he's telling the truth
I mean I honestly don't I there is no
answer for that I can't figure that
explain what exactly it's like I have no
idea what she's thinking it's to me it
seems like she's just not doing her job
like she's literally just saying like
reading facts about the person and being
like well I have no analytical
standpoint from this at all I'm just
gonna read these facts back to you and
you just affirm what you think you know
and and the problem is it's like God in
that interview I remember when that
first came out but it's like hearing her
say so you're saying that women will
have rights and he goes on to to say you
know he yes
women will refers to things in a hee hee
hee hee and at which point if I was the
reporter I would you know question that
you know if you're I just directly ask
you ask you something about women and
you're referring to them and a he
standpoint like women don't even exist
but she goes on to just completely
smooth everything over yeah I don't know
and and honestly it takes I love I
generally like Sienna I think it takes
away credibility like you know of this
reporting quality if you will sorry so
I mean I said get away I think she goes
along with it because I think it's you
know the opportunity to sit down with
you know huge people and I think you
know these people are cool with sitting
down with a journalist that they know
it's not gonna it's not gonna you know
give them the hard time if you see all
her interview they're not really
interviews to me an interview is you ask
someone a question they respond and you
either affirm that or maybe you're like
wait a minute stop you know she doesn't
really do back and forth it's kind of
like ask a question whatever you say
that's cool all right next question yeah
you know it's like that's not an
interview to me you know and so I think
that's what it is in it and it
unfortunately essentially turns out to
be just totally that a platform for them
to just come and say hey everything we
saw how fantastic that turned out
exactly you know so then why don't why
don't people talk about it I don't think
I'm that much of a genius that I was
eight I mean I remembered watching that
clip two years ago and then I saw the
rule on e1 and I was like I got to show
these things back to back why doesn't
the media do it is it really just
because they want to keep getting I'm
obviously not interviewing rou-ha-nee
and yeah Ali wouldn't sit down right but
is it just because they just want to be
like well I mean it's like the White
House correspondent yeah like you want
to cozy up to the president and you want
to get the I mean you have to think like
in a sense you know he's not sitting
down with everyone you know he's sitting
down with her and it probably is like
you said he feels comfortable so maybe
it's said that they're providing you
with the information that they're laying
out on the table and then you can take
that and either take it at face value or
you could read in between lines as as do
the smart people of this panel
I love how if you watch the clip but you
can watch the whole thing on YouTube she
asked him again about the Holocaust
which of course akhmad Energy odd had
denied and he says well I'm not a
historian I like and then she just she
does exactly what you say but she's
instead of following up and saying well
it's not about the story they're a
historic standing in the rain and being
like well I'm not a meteorologist you
know great like it's not like are you
really conceding that much by saying
that the Holocaust happened like is that
that much of a concession like bad stuff
can happen and it can happen on both
sides